okay
good morning there's more of your crew
grateful that you're here
good morning everyone seeing as though
it's uh 10 now 01 we're going to open
this hearing today work session and
budget work session for the record those
of you that are here and online I'm
representative Maureen Mooney I'm the
vice chair of division three our
chairman Jess Edwards couldn't be here
today
so just to kick off I do have at some
point a hearing I have to introduce a
bill in division two and I'm not
entirely sure the timing of when I'll be
up but at that point I will pass the
gavel to the finance Vice chair and that
is Representative Keith erf at some
point today
so I know that we're we're missing
representative hole today at least this
morning and
um not sure about others but that's
where we are so today
we're going to pick it up
with
a work session on division of long-term
supports and services I'm assuming that
uh Mr White will take the stand as well
as whoever he invites and if you could
just let us know the page number we'll
be starting from that would be helpful
and at this point all members of
division three should have in their
possession uh what we refer to as the
coloring book now I've noticed about
today's presentation and then also the
budget book both all right welcome to
both of you but before we begin is there
anything that the members would like to
bring up or discuss at this time
all right we are good to go welcome both
of you to division three and just let us
know the page number we're working for
and begin when you're ready of course
good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer of the Department of
Health and Human Services and I'm joined
here today with good morning I'm Melissa
Hardy I am the division director for
long-term supports and services welcome
and uh just to start just to get
everybody oriented
um today we will be starting if you turn
to the governor's recommended budget
page 925
and before you you have two separate
documents that have been provided as
well there's the the PowerPoint
presentation or or the coloring book
um as it's been referred to and then we
uh also have the the budget briefing
book here as well Melissa is going to be
walking us through the PowerPoint
presentation and I'll be throughout the
presentation I'll be referencing the
appropriate page within the governor's
recommended budget as we move through
that so with no further Ado I will hand
it over to Melissa
foreign
thank you Nathan um again thank you for
the opportunity to walk through the
division of long-term supports and
services budget
for the most part it'll be me myself and
Nathan up here but we do have some
Supporting Cast behind us my three
Bureau Chiefs
um along with Henry Littman our Medicaid
director so they're here for support if
we if we need to phone a friend they're
here for us so
um we're thankful for that also Kyra
Leonard our finance director is here as
well
so our goals obviously to move through
the budgets and to give you kind of a
high level overview of the division with
the opportunity to pause and ask any
questions so if you turn to slide two
this is really just our overall mission
for the bureau so the division works
collaboratively with providers and
communities to support children adults
and Families
to be as independent as desired
throughout the lifespan so as I move
through this presentation you'll notice
that we provide supports and services
for children youth with special health
care or complex medical needs adults
with developmental disabilities and
acquired brain disorders and supports
and services for the Aging and
physically disabled population so we
kind of cover from birth to aging
uh slide three it's just again a brief
overview of the division we have three
bureaus so the Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services
which provides comprehensive and
coordinated services for older adults
ages 60 and older and adults with
disabilities between the ages of 18 and
59.
we also have the Bureau of family
centered Services which identifies and
coordinates supports that assist
children from birth to 21 years of age
who have are at risk for a chronic
medical condition disability or a
special Health Care need
and then finally we have the Bureau of
Developmental Services which partners
with provider organizations to deliver
community-based supports and services
for adults and children with
developmental disabilities and acquired
um slide number four is just a quick uh
org chart high level org chart of the
division
Slide Five reviews the overall positions
for each of the bureaus within the
department of long-term supports and
services
so you'll note
um a higher number of overall positions
in the Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services and this number includes 70
positions that we have in Adult
Protective Services in that program that
operate out of 11 district offices so
that's why you see that number
significantly more than our other two
bureaus
on slide six
I like to briefly highlight some key
division outcomes per Bureau and you can
see them here I think for the Bureau of
um
elderly and Adult Services we've really
strengthened our APS program in
investing in education for our APS
workers and response times to I know
during covid there was some lagging and
response times due to the workforce in
the pandemic and so we've really
improved our response times to
um calls are answered in the same day
our registry inquiries are answered I
think by Statute it's by it's five days
but we're averaging one to two days for
for a registry check
and we've been working through a
contract on structured decision making
which really helps the aps workers with
assessing risk assessing safety and it's
a standardized tool so that's something
that we're currently doing
um in APS
um we also want to make sure that we
support and promote active and healthy
Aging in the Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services
um
and and things like strengthening food
security and social supports for older
adults through home delivered meals and
congregate meals some other supplemental
food programs they were piloting like a
grab-and-go uh meal program or a local
restaurants would have kind of like a
bagged lunch or a bag dinner where
people can pick it up
um but also promoting awareness for for
programming that we have so
um making sure that they understand that
they can go to our aging and disability
Resource Center also known as service
links with our counties to be able to be
provided information about what services
are available either through the state
or through Medicare Medicaid also we
have an Alzheimer's disease and related
dementia program that provides respite
and some self management of chronic care
and diseases so
um that's a quick uh overview of the key
outcomes for beas
for the Bureau of family centered
services
uh you know really supporting children
and their families with special Health
Care needs to have access to
community-based services within their
community and providing community-based
specialty clinics in consultation and
Coordinated Care which is inclusive of
family support
for the Bureau of Developmental Services
um we want timely delivery of services
in the community and develop a service
delivery system for all individuals to
have access equal access across the
state to the services that are available
so we partner with 10 Regional area
agencies
um and they're the community-based
provider and communities provider
Network through the area agencies to
deliver service for those who are
eligible under statute for developmental
services
any questions
so far from the committee
I think we're in good shape okay
moving to slide seven we're talking
about some key accomplishments
um so I I added a division level
accomplishment because over the past
year and a half we've been able to
distribute about 25 million dollars in
arpa funding to Direct Care Workforce
through our community community-based
organizations and providers for
recruiting retention staff training and
case management
um so we were able to push that money
directly to the providers
we also are working on the electronic
visit verification which is a federal
requirement under the century cures act
which
um
we have been out of compliance with
um so we have a good a good uh Faith
effort extension that we received where
we're working with CMS to have
implementation of January of next year
so we were able to get that good faith
exemption as we work with our
contractors to get the evv technology
started
um for the Bureau of um elderly and
Adult Services
I think again we are talking a lot about
the the aps Workforce investment
training that I talked about on the
previous slide we were also able to
renew our choices for Independence
waiver which is our 1915 C Medicaid
waiver for community-based care
so we were able to renew that in June or
June yeah June of 22. and we've also
secured a Federal grant called Money
Follows the person
uh which you may have heard called
Community passport program we've had the
Grant in the past before
um but really looking at community-based
care for individuals
um instead of institutionalized care so
we received that Grant
for the Bureau of family centered
services
um
we were able to look at quality
improvement and restructuring of our
health care coordination so
um the the bureau with stakeholder
engagement identified opportunities for
improvements for children with special
Health Care needs and their families and
the bureau adopted national standards of
care coordination for those children's
special Health Care needs via the
National Academy for State Health policy
um this Bureau also has worked really
hard
um for Workforce internally
um I believe
um last last budget round we were about
a 40 vacancy rate and in in this Bureau
and the bureau chief has worked really
hard to make sure that we have
appropriate Staffing within the bureau
and I believe we have just two open
positions in that Bureau at this time
so a significant
focus on the workforce
just if I could I do have I just want to
swing back to that Grant Money Follows
the person probably a good time to ask
we've had discussion about federal
grants previous and uh that's very
onerous sometimes to apply for them and
then there's various conditions ranging
from maybe a paragraph to multiple Pages
uh could you just tell us the experience
of this particular Grant and what
particular strings for lack of a better
word are attached if any sure I think
Vince Grant is a little more flexible
than the previous Money Follows the
person Grant
um it's a it's up to five years and it's
really structured in a couple of
different components so
previously like I said it was called the
community passport program which really
had stringent
um
eligibility requirements for people who
are looking to transition out of Nursing
Home Care into the community so you had
to be in the nursing home X number of
months but by the time you're in a
nursing home for X number of months you
have no housing to go to
um so they were able to transition 300
individuals in the previous program out
of nursing homes back into the community
but those restrictions as far as
eligibility requirements are lesser in
this grant
um than they were in previous years
and we have some time I believe it's a
16 month stakeholder engagement process
where Wendy Altman the bureau chief we
were able to hire
um two positions to facilitate the
stakeholder engagement do the data
analytics
um so we're we're excited for this I
think we can
um have up to five million dollars on
this grant so
um we really think it'll be able to give
us A needs assessment and a gaps
analysis that will be able to study
long-term supports and services and
utilization Trends and current gaps in
community-based services
and and from a from a budget perspective
um it's it's on page 931 of the
governor's recommended budget and and
the two positions are backing up even
further
um this was ex this this grant was
initially accepted through fiscal the
state fiscal year
um the two positions that Melissa was
referring to those are in class 59 those
are the temporary full-time positions
um there's no history in the 23 adjusted
authorized just because it was accepted
through fiscal this fall
um after after the budget process had
begun so if if there are any questions
on the details I appreciate that because
my next question was going to be the
location so you're obviously has been
with us long enough to know and
anticipate these questions
representative erf
did you say it pays 931
931 yes
I don't see any positions you sell zeros
there or yep so so these are in class 59
so they're the temporary full-time so
the governor's recommended budget only
includes the full-time authorized
positions in that count yeah and and so
I had sent the I'd sent the committee
the um the totals for the part-time a
temporary and full-time temporary
separately just because those those
aren't captured within the system today
um and then lastly for the Bureau of
Developmental Services we're moving um
in the direction of our federal
compliance with our corrective action
plan with the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services as it relates to
direct billing requirements and
conflict-free case management I'm sure
you might have heard of the BDS systems
redesign work that we're doing and
that's um that's kind of before the
redesign work that we've had this
corrective action plan since 2017. we've
had multiple extensions and so our
compliance state for direct billing and
conflict-free case management is 7-1 of
this year so we're moving toward that
representative erf for a question so
just to back up to the two temp
full-time position or the two
yeah 10 full-time positions so is the
so
um
the state's process for well they are
full-time but but they're they're the
class 59 the temporary
um there's a process for the state so
basically every February last February
we actually started the budget process
it's for us it's an 18-month long
Endeavor
um and we actually start at that point
where we look at positions and we make
requests to the governor's office for
you've heard some folks say the 9t
conversions and that's where we're
requesting to convert a full-time
temporary position into a full-time
authorized position to become part of
that total roughly 3 200 Personnel count
that our department has
so you did not do that for these
positions
we did not because this item went to
fiscal I believe just this past November
so so many months after that process had
transpired
is the intention that they become
full-time
classified full-time this is a five-year
Grant
um so I don't at this point in time
don't have any intention of having those
be full-time permanent authorized
positions just because those are funded
through the Grant and it's a temporary
another area I want to touch upon for
for the Bureau of Developmental services
um is is our systems change work that
you might have heard of so we are
working on with with throat Contracting
with with providers
um
developing uh provider Service rates new
rates provider education working with
the stakeholders on several committees
um in order to
get their input on future state of BDS
or the Bureau of Developmental services
so it's kind of twofold one is our
corrective action plan through CMS that
our compliance date is July 1st of this
year and then these other systems change
work would be after that seven one date
but we're already engaging stakeholders
and families and providers in the
process
and one thing we're really excited about
I just heard you say that you were
working on Contracting and
um I think you said something about
adjusting rates so in this area are they
receiving the three percent rate
increase or are you are there other
rates that are being suggested for this
group
sure so for for this group um this had
come up
um excuse me so if you turn to page uh
this is this is where funds funds are
are included in the budget and Melissa I
don't know if you want me to hold off or
okay
um so part of part of the
transformational work that that Melissa
has has been leading with her team is
ensuring that that we are compliant with
with a variety of federal regulations
um but but what they've done you'll see
in classline
um if you if you look at classline 103
contracts for Op Services that
represents the dad's rate or the
administrative rate
um that the area agencies will will be
claiming and basically because we've
been given funds for that and that that
and that rate we have to budget that
rate separately
um
those numbers there will allow us to
provide a three percent service rate
increase to the existing services today
because we were funded at the 15 million
dollar for the dad's rate
so so because of that we have sufficient
funds within the class 502 for that
and then last but not least excuse me
once more representative Stringham for a
question
since since we're on uh 10 10 42 so
we're we're seeing a pretty you know
significant rise in payment to Providers
uh above three percent so that would
seem to indicate that you got an
increased volume of those of either
Services service intensity or number of
individuals receiving Services
um can you talk about that at all yeah I
would say it's a variety of those right
so we haven't
um updated our rates really since 20
seven oh seven yeah 2007 for providers
for folks um providing services for DD
so some of that increase takes that into
consideration
um we're also seeing you know the cost
of services going up from providers and
the cost to retain and recruit direct
service Professionals in order to do the
work which is where we see some of that
going can I just follow up first is that
all right
um so can you comment on what the wait
list is now and for those currently in
the system to what degree they're having
success
uh having those Services provided at the
current current rates sure so I can
speak to
as of last month
um we don't have and I want to kind of
differentiate we have nobody on the wait
list for funding everybody
um is funded for services through
through BDS who are on the wait list
however I in in working with the area
agencies what we find is that even
though they have the funding of some of
the people who don't start Services is
because they can't find staff or
providers to provide the service so even
though the funding's been approved the
budget's been approved for example our
latest statistics is that out of the 448
folks that we funded on the
developmental disabilities waiver with a
projection of a start date
um 65 percent are receiving services and
35 percent are not
um because of like I said uh lack of
providers and staff to provide that
funded service
so it's a 65 if it's okay I'm 65 are
they receiving all of the services
they're entitled to or at least some at
least some
full or partial
to all part of my next bullet is our I.T
system but we do all this work currently
collecting these numbers manually
through through BDS and through the area
agencies so we're hoping we'll have
better and quicker numbers through our
new it system to track and be able to
trend is somebody getting 100 of their
services early early getting 50 of their
services
so with this with this increase from 347
to 414 and 417 would you expect that 65
percent number to go up in the next in
this coming biennium to something higher
than 65 percent
um or or are we treading water at these
numbers yeah it's hard to tell I mean I
think we we really need to focus on
Workforce and I'm sure that's something
that you've heard probably throughout
everyone's uh presentation they think
that's really one of the the biggest
barriers in getting services to people
is having a Workforce
um to be able to provide that part of
our service rate development is looking
at the direct service professional rate
and benefits so that's really the
building block of the new rates that
we're developing so we're hoping that
really makes a difference in enticing
folks as we start off
um developing rates based on DSP rates
thank you go ahead
okay representative Wallner for a
so did I just hear you say that you had
not increased the rate since 2007.
yeah we have not had a rate study since
2007 so I believe there's been
incremental
um like Medicaid across the board rate
increases but not not a rate study to
see if the cost of services
um
is what the rate provides
so one thing I've wondered for a while
with all the services is this three
percent rate increase
and everyone is having Workforce
problems
how realistic is it that a three percent
rate increase is actually going to be
able to help the area agencies address
this shortage of workers which then
means that we aren't providing the level
yeah and I think I think part of that is
um as we're developing the service
provider rates it's not necessarily that
three percent we're really looking and
Gathering costs from providers to
develop a base rate that takes into
consideration the cost of workers so
we're hoping working with the our um
contractor Myers and staff are there a
rate setting entity in an actuary firm
that they will get and receive cost
reporting data from providers and area
agencies about how much it costs to
provide our specific services and build
the rate off of that
and when will that be complete
well complete um we're hoping let me
find my little timeline here
um we're starting we started with the
area agency administrative rate which we
um completed this past month and so we
are now starting with the the direct
Service rates so we're hoping to have
draft rates by the end of this year
to be able to there's some legislation
going on to Pilot or test those rates to
see if they're sufficient so we're
working
um with the area agencies and those
providers as to what piloting those
rates would look like and would that be
thank you just want to be sure that
microphone is picking up everything
you're saying for our YouTube audience
I'm probably a little slow here
so if I understand what you're saying
the lines
103 and 502 uh contracts drop services
and payment providers The Fairly large
increase there in both those lines would
be due to rate increases that you're
anticipating putting into effect is that
correct
no no so I just told you I was slow
short and and I I think we we kind of
launched into things without without
kind of diving into some of the kind of
structural basis for it so part of the
reason that we're setting up this
administrative rate separately is
because under Medicaid we we have to
track that separately traditionally it
was we weren't tracking it separately
and so now the the 397 the 345 figures
you see there in in the class 502 that
will represent the the Medicaid uh
provider service figures versus the dads
rate which that will be uh paid to the
area agencies so it's it's we're
separating that out so the 397 there
what you see there is you're seeing a
projected increase
um in in the needs from from from the
data that we have available today so we
are anticipating an increase
um in individuals that that would come
into the into the system
okay so by the way his dad is an acronym
or are you talking about people like me
you know it is an acronym um I didn't
make it up but it's um the designated
Erie agency delivery System rate okay
that's okay
um
so back to the
103 could just
explain that one
again
it's like
uh no okay
sure
yeah so for the dads rate
um let me just turn to my page here
we're still on page 1043 in our budget
books
okay so
um in developing the stat rate we worked
with the area agencies on again
collecting their costs
um surveys as far as it what does it
cost the area agency to provide
administrative services not Direct Care
Services administrative services to
families and individuals who are
eligible under 171a for developmental
services
historically that cost has been coming
out of and this is where you'll hear
about the three percent
it comes out of an individual's budget
to fund that administrative rate so what
we've done is taking those
administrative functions came up with a
rate that includes intake and
eligibility that includes ongoing
provision of services on a monthly basis
for anyone that is receiving Area Agency
services and was able to develop an
administrative rate for those
administrative costs so when we talk
about the three percent going back to
the providers since we were able to get
a dad's rate for administrative costs
we're passing along that three percent
that normally would come out of a
person's budget back into the budget for
providers for services
okay just adjust so if I'm clear so
previously
those 103 numbers would have been
included
in the 502 lines basically the same
providers are getting the payments it's
just just you know tracking it which I
like
um it's separate the administrative
costs from exactly from the actual cost
of providing Services yes thank you very
much yeah so we do have the we have
presented the rates for the dad's
administrative costs right now they're
with um CMS for approval
um and so we should hear from them soon
we hope
um and then our work now is now pivoting
toward the provider rate
hmm
representative walner
so I think I heard you say that
at this point we don't have a wait list
because everyone does have a budget
yes everyone's been fun to have have a
budget but we're only really delivering
65 of the services
yeah that was for the the developmental
disabilities waiver so that's the
information that we've received from the
area agencies that yes the department
has funded all the requests however
because of Workforce shortage and lack
of providers everyone is not getting
their full complement of service so
they're not drawing down all the funds
that are available could be available
for families is that right sure so how
much are we lapsing in that area and
how how are we handling the lapses there
so so the the hb1 numbers
um that that are before you today
um we there there there's an hb2
provision that would allow us to carry
forward the funds that would that would
otherwise lapse from this biennium
um right now our conservative estimate
is about 55 million dollars and and
those funds are needed to cover to to
cover the wait list costs in 24
um however right now we we are still
estimating that we may not have
sufficient funds within the state fiscal
year 25 cup earners recommended to cover
all of the waitlist costs
um there is a there is a a legislative
requirement
um that that requires that we fund that
so when we submitted our agency budget
requests we included in our prioritized
needs funds sufficient at that time
based on those projections to cover that
um right now it it doesn't necessarily
appear that that we have funds
sufficient in the second year say fiscal
year 25 to cover the full wait list
um however that also assumes that the
hb2 provision uh that is included today
uh stays true otherwise if we're not
allowed to carry those funds forward
um then we would have a problem further
complicating this is is that this
account is actually it's actually
non-lapsing so it's a little unique in
the sense that sometimes our non-lapsing
accounts may be off books you know so
those funds versus here where you're you
know you're reappropriating General
funds every year and and there are
General funds here so
so where in which section of house bill
2.
thank you
it's really
everything
great thank you as we go through
this budget today as we continue through
there it would be really helpful to me
at least if you would talk about any
house any house bill two sections that
also relate to this and how how they
work together and how we for instance
you've just pointed out it's important
that we keep this section in House Bill
2 to make the rest of this work
absolutely thank you yes and we've all
been provided printouts of House Bill 2
representative Stringham recognized for
a question in terms of your prioritized
need I mean aside from the 20 percent
that the was in the governor's budget
um uh if I understand
um you know looking at your budget book
here on page 18 that you requested
um
so it was going from 347 to 417
um from 2023 to the governor's budget in
2025 but you actually requested 592
million dollars on the developmental
Services waiver
as a prioritized need I guess in order
to fulfill
um
uh well not not the wait list but I
guess the Gap in in Services provided
can you talk at all about how that
agency request number came and
um
what the impact will be if we just have
the governor's budget uh item on there
and it looks like just the caseload
numbers are the same in both cases so
um I'll just leave that to you there
sure so so I I will let me address the
the budget side first
um so so the when we put our agency
budget together we're putting it
together back in August
um the data systems that that we do rely
on as Melissa indicated earlier we are
we are seeking to upgrade those to give
us better and more accurate information
um based on the most recent analysis uh
we we would need approximately
64 million dollars total 50 50 Federal
General
in-state fiscal year for for all the
waitlist services
um that that would be required and
Melissa I don't know if you want to
yeah so um again because of
um we haven't had any sort of rate
changes or significant rate studies
since 20 2007
um we were projecting that the cost of
those services and the new service
Suites would go up as we're doing this
um so so basically you're saying in part
that the rates um uh the need might not
be as great as it was at the time you
developed a prioritized list
um and um is the current budget then
fully funding
what you what you're what you think you
need in order to reduce the wait list
um for those already in the system or is
it partially does it partially get you
there
so so 24 is is fully funded provided the
hb2 provision
um uh 232 I believe it was uh stands
um for 25 we would still need the
additional 32 million dollars of General
funds
um and and that assumes
um that that assumes you know that that
the weight in order to ensure that the
wait list is covered we would need those
funds now we will still of course have
the challenge of of the provider issue
in the community which is why we're
projected to lapse roughly 55 million
thank you may proceed
okay turning to slide eight just a few
key challenges I think we talked a lot
about
um workforces not just in developmental
Services we have Workforce issues
um on the Aging and Disability side and
also with our Bureau of family centered
services
um you know philosophically
incorporating you know all of our work
is person-centered incorporating that
within our everyday practice and policy
decisions and our guidance that we
receive from CMS
um I I cannot
um emphasize enough that adequate I.T
system for us to be able to automate
some of these
um areas that we manually or really do
on an Excel spreadsheet and you know
provide uh that sort of information so
we're not physically counting things but
also being able to pay our providers
quicker right now it's a paper paper
service on the developmental disability
side where
um we have a department that gets
paperwork from the providers and then
they have to push that through in order
to pay them and in our new system a lot
of those processes will be automatic so
we're excited that that will be able to
get payments out to Providers a lot
quicker
and then just kind of
um limited staff like I said our
staffing is is pretty good with within
the division with seven open positions
but we've been really focusing on
recruiting
um and retaining employees but
um you know sometimes there are
additional things that come on board
like a new grant that
um you know that we spend some time on
um so just having kind of limited staff
to maintain current operations but then
anything else that may pop up
um that we need to focus our attention
on
foreign
nine and ten go into
um
the accounting units for the Bureau of
elderly and Adult Services so just a
quick kind of recap Bureau of elderly
and Adult Services administers The Adult
Protective Services programs
funds home and community-based services
for non-medicaid eligible individuals
also the Aging and Disability Resource
Center service link is under the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services
and nursing facilities and our choices
for Independence Medicaid waiver that
approximately serves about 3 800 older
and and I I don't know if this is a Time
whether you'd like to go through those
accounting units and ask any questions
or not
um but you just want to put that out
there
I was thinking that would be appropriate
uh why don't we go through that sure if
we could so we'll start on page 925 is
that the starting point that is the
starting point all right
and again I I don't want to make it an
all-day Affair but I I think you're with
me in terms of uh going through as
thoroughly as we can yeah so um in in uh
so 92.50 uh beginning on page 925 going
on to page 926. um as most indicated
earlier this is where bulk of the
positions are the Adult Protective
Service workers
um one one change you will see in class
10 we did previously have unfunded
positions uh we we've funded uh a few of
those positions in this biennium and and
that's why you see that increase in the
class 10 there on page 925.
um you'll also see the in the class uh
50 on the subsequent page uh we we also
added added a a position there as well
um and then we we were able to fill one
of the existing uh temperate positions
uh with somebody that had a lot of
experience so we had to hire them at a
higher labor grade which is part of the
part of the reason for the increase in
that line there uh the the federal funds
uh these are these are Medicaid admin
funds we actually have to conduct a Time
study uh on an ongoing basis for that
but primarily
um the remaining roughly 90 of the funds
in this in this account are General
funds
representative walner
in this so this is the unit where the
Protective Service workers are so what
is the caseload that the
sure so
um
my case load right here and we so we
have different district offices so the
case loads are a little bit different
but for the total
um from seven one of 21 to 6 30 of 22 uh
we had about 4069 cases total
um we are working
um with the union and some um
APS
workers on what's a national standard
for caseload there isn't one for APF as
there are for maybe some other
protective work so we're really looking
at you know what types of cases can we
do we need to you know maybe it's more
of an information and referral or is it
somebody looking to get on Medicaid or
is it truly somebody who's at risk for
abuse neglect exploitation
so um the 70 workers that we have
how many what is their caseload how many
are they averaging
um so again it's it's different because
they're all um designated in different
district offices
um so we're looking at anywhere between
I believe the the most recent number
provide you a copy of uh the case gold
report too if that would be helpful
representative Stringham per question
um it's the caseload are those numbers
similar to what's on in the budget book
under the
yes
if there are no other questions uh on on
that account we can move to the next
it's 78 72 administrative Administration
on Aging
um your your personnel lines on page 926
stay relatively stagnant with the
um on page 927 the class 40 the indirect
cost line that's zeroed out um that's
part of that centralization of our
indirect costs into ocom and to account
9 500.
um this this account and I I'll let
Melissa speak to this more in detail um
there's approximately 69 contracts that
are funded out of this out of this
account and most I don't know if you
want to talk a little bit about those
yeah sure so we contract for services
um under the older Americans act title 3
program and the nutrition service
incentive program so this
um really pays for things like home
delivered and congregate meals
Transportation caregiver support
Medicare counseling Home Health Services
Adult Day Services senior companion
programs
and um representative Wallner for a
question
if you can just talk a little more about
the home delivered meals and the
congregate meals and what I'd really be
interested in is
what we are providing as a rate for
those meals and is there a rate increase
built in
um
you know just talk a little bit more
so um
in in-house Bill 2 on page 82 section 2
255.
um there is an appropriation made for
nutrition and transportation services
and the department had made this request
because we had received temporary
one-time funding uh from the federal
government and we had provided a rate
increase at that time and this would
continue this hb2 provision would
continue that rate increase without it
we would either have to reduce rates or
Services I I don't have the specific
figure for what the rate increase was at
the time I don't know if you have
Melissa
index opening up spreadsheet and we're
also when you're there looking for the
section in-house built 2.
it was section 255 it's it's on page 82.
it appropriates uh 3.4 million dollars
of General funds in each year of the
biennium
approximately
yes so the cost per meal is eight
dollars and 11 cents currently
that's the cost and what is that what we
are that's the rate yes that's the rate
okay
um
so this section 255
that is here in house bill 2.
that will that is really not an increase
over what they're getting now because
this just keeps them at flat yeah yeah
it maintains what we provided through
our funding for this year okay so what
is there something here for next year
and the next year rate increase
we we do not currently have anything in
our budget for that
so no rate increase for Meals on Wheels
or congregate meals
in this in this particular
representative erf for a question
so just understand what representative
Walden was asking there so that three or
four million dollars whatever that was
that's on top of the four million
dollars that's in
yes yep so so that would be in addition
to the in addition to the the figures uh
that you see here in the 500 series yes
and part of that is that arpa was
already providing that additional
funding in the current biennium I
believe it was arpa funds or some
federal funds yes it was arpa funds okay
yes and previous to that so pre-covet I
I I don't want to speculate I would
assume so
um I I'll go back and verify okay
and so what is the jump more services
and that's like a doubling right of
what's here yeah so there was a a
discussion about increasing the the rate
of the meal versus reducing the number
of actual meals to cover the costs of
the meal provider so food costs were
going up
um and so Wendy and her team had
discussions with the meal providers to
talk about if we were able to add this
additional funding would it go towards a
rate or would it go towards more meals
but because of the cost of meals going
up we increased the rate not enough not
necessarily the amount of units okay and
then regarding 541 the
the other part of it
so I'm guessing that if we're not
guessing fy22 is actual
fy23 is adjusted actual which brought
money over from FY 22. so that's
basically an increase over the current
biennium carry forward to the next
biennium is there what accounts for that
if I have that correct if I understand
uh representative can you can you
clarify which class line you're
referring to 541 is that correct
okay
so 541 was it was budgeted at uh
approximately 2 2.25 million dollars
well that doesn't quite make sense does
it because or does the money not lapse I
mean uh Carey good carried forward from
23 to 24. so from 22 to 23 excuse me so
we we so we we don't for for this
particular account we we don't have the
authority to carry those funds forward
unless they're encumbered oh okay thank
you
foreign
ER could I just ask one more question
about Meals on Wheels and congregate
meals do we do they the providers
presently have a waiting list
of
um clients that are eligible
I'll have to get back to you I don't we
don't have the answer if there's uh
waiting lists for folks who signed up
representative talerski for a question
thank you
it's supposed to just give us an idea of
the number of
people who rely on this service either
on a daily basis or the number of meals
served
yeah I don't have the actual number with
you but um Wendy will get that for you
but it's it's a significant amount of
I don't want to say what she said but
you know hundreds of thousands of meals
that we do provide uh I can get you kind
of what we what we've paid out in meals
and wheels in congregate yeah I'm really
just curious how many people on a daily
basis require this service
representative Stringham for question
um in the budget book on page four it
has caseload listed under Bureau of
elderly and Adult Services you know 30
30 31 000
um is that number a daily
eligible of people to get these kind of
so this caseload number would be
inclusive of not just meals but some of
the other services that I had talked
about meaning Home Care
Transportation Services
caregiver support those those type of
services
thank you
um if we turn to page
you have account
89 17 this is a relatively small Federal
grant that's under title 3D
um
I don't know if there's any questions
representative walner for question so
how do the Meals on Wheels
um
on this page relate to the other page
and as
the section in House Bill 2
is part of the sectionary hospital to go
cover the rate increase here okay this
is so so so so you're you're on page 927
is that correct
I'm on page 928 it's called Social
Service block grant and this is the
yep
so so we have a couple of different okay
so we have our contracts over here and
and we pay for those contracts through a
number of different uh funding sources
and so so some of the funding sources
are within 78.72
and then we have the so the the ssbg the
social services block grant out of 92.55
and we also use funds from that
accounting unit to to pay for those
contracts and and so those those
contracts the total price limitation of
those will have dollars coming from this
account and that account so so the the
hb2 provision uh section 255
um that that that that that still holds
true that that would essentially hold
those rates at the same rate but that's
the relationship between those it's an
excellent question though so in order to
know how much we're actually spending on
this program you have to sort of add
those to different categories together
as well as House Bill 2. yep I mean
another way to think about it too is is
we could pull we could pull the
contracts that we currently have and
those contracts each one has a has a
price limitation
um that that set that that's a better
kind of amalgamation of the numbers that
you're seeing here
all set okay
um so we just talked about uh
net 9255 at the bottom of 928
um and the social services block grant
is is a huge component of the funding
source for that account
the on page 929 the 8925 Medicaid
services Grant this is the ship Grant
um there's a small required general fund
match that the dollar amount is you know
roughly 150 000 annually
um I don't know if there's any questions
on the functions of this particular
account
representative walner thank you so I I
do see under this is a very small a very
small area but I see under
um 566 the adult group daycare
it doesn't look like we
have been spending down in that area and
I'm wondering is that because the
eligibility is so low that
there aren't very many clients who need
this service
this is not it's on page 928 at the
bottom of the page
do you know that yeah I would say part
of that is true and then I think you
know we're still seeing the effects of
coven so for seniors to be in congregate
settings I think we've seen a drop
um in seniors wanting to be in that sort
of group setting you anticipate that
people will start using it again that's
what we're hoping you know to support
the caregivers um in the community it's
a real vital service
um so people can continue working as
their caregiving for their older family
members great thank you and and also
just just from a kind of day-to-day
process perspective
um we you know we we review our expense
projections on an ongoing basis and so
sometimes if we do see that you know
we're we're not projected to use all
those funds we will go back through
fiscal to repurpose those
um for for other pressing needs where
you know we do project a potential
deficits or or they could be spent in a
better way
thanks
so turning to page
um let's see here
so actually I think if we go back to the
presentation at this point and move to
to page 10.
um we're we're actually we've actually
already started moving into the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services uh just to
get everybody oriented
um so on um on page 930 we formally had
a no wrong door uh Grant this this is
since expired and and will be will be
going away
um at the bottom of page 930 we have the
administration on Aging Services Grant
this is also a relatively small small
dollar figure
um and and this and I don't know if you
want to speak to the program here
Melissa's senior Medicaid sure it's a
senior
senior troll project so it's a contract
with service link
um really dedicated to teaching seniors
and other people with Medicare to be
aware of you know Health Care fraud any
sort of schemes that may come so that
it'll become victims of Fraud and how to
detect any sort of billing errors on
your Medicare statement
um so that's that program
foreign
on the next page on page 931 this is the
Money Follows the person's grant that we
talked about earlier and and the the two
um temporary positions and and that we
had uh had it approved through fiscal uh
this past fall and that's a five-year
if you continue to page
um 9 32
uh we we now get into the uh there's a
volunteer activities account uh this
this is a hundred percent General funds
it's a relatively small program
um but but it does pay for a a small
stipend and transportation reimbursement
on at the bottom of page 932 we get into
our our service Link account and I'm
going to hand it over to Melissa just to
kind of talk about the the program and
um the the seven contracts that we have
13 locations across the state
yes so service link is our state
designated aging and disability resource
center and I'm sure you might have heard
of them
um before they're like Nathan said we
have seven contracts with different
providers and 13 physical locations and
it really braids federal and state
funding for things like information and
referral Options Counseling
benefits counseling and caregiver
support so
um it also has the New Hampshire family
caregiver support program the state
health insurance assistance program the
scene that's where the senior Medicare
Patrol program is housed and also a
veterans directed CARE program so
um
yeah that that's that's service link so
kind of a One-Stop shop for folks that
can either go in person or make an
appointment or a virtual appointment
um to see you know what services the
state and local communities provide and
excellent thank you for the explanation
a lot could have been determined from
the word service link so it's good to
have that clearly detailed out
okay and and and the the funding sources
for this are are multi-fold they they
are listed out in the um in the budget
briefing book there's a lot of acronyms
I'm more than happy to get any
information you need for that
uh moving on on page 933 there's the
Alzheimer's Related Disorders um this is
a hundred percent General funds uh we we
have a contract with an Area Agency resp
for respite for families
here
okay if if you move to page 934
um we're now moving into into one of the
larger accounts uh this is the 2152 so
um when when we talk about the county
cap
um this is this is the the accounting
unit that's impacted
um I think I think it's
um maybe important to start down below
and skip the expenditures and start at
the revenues and just talk a little bit
about about the funding mechanism here
so we we use this account to
um to cover the Medicaid costs of
individuals that are receiving
um
services at nursing facilities and there
is a um a system in place in statute
whereby the the counties make payments
uh to the state and there's a cap on the
on the level of payment that is made and
you'll see those those private local
funds
um when we talk County cap that's what
you're seeing there there there is a
discrepancy between the figures that are
included here and the figures that are
included in the hb2 and and I can I can
pull that provision up here just so
we're all looking at the same thing
foreign it's uh page 80 section 233
um and and so
these these figures should match the
figures that are uh identified in RSA
167 18a
um these numbers should match
um and if they were to St and there's
there's also a provision within RSA 167
18a
that specifies that the county cap
should not increase by over two percent
each year so if if it were to and and
I'll defer to the committee on on their
Direction on this if it were to increase
um
by two percent each year the figures in
24 and 25 and the private local funds
would be a 129 million and 131 million
and 24 and 25
um that that would result in an increase
in the general fund uh need by
approximately an increase of 2 million
uh and
um about eight million dollars in state
fiscal year
2025. uh the federal funds that you see
there those are the Medicaid dollars or
the matching Medicaid dollars and then
the general funds
um those are the the remaining amount
that the state puts in
um now within this in back in the
expenditures UC class 504 the nursing
home payments um you I believe an
organization came up and spoke to you
last week about the choices for
Independence program and assisted living
um within 505 that is the assisted
living the home support waiver Services
uh that's that's when somebody comes to
your to your house to provide assistance
and then the Home Health Care Services
is more Health Care related Services
um so historically those have been or
right I don't know if historically is
the best word but most recently those
figure those the 504 504 or sorry 505
506 and 529 account uh class lines those
have been budgeted separately the
department was proposing and and we're
fine with it one way or another we were
proposing to combine those class lines
into a single account the reason for
that is partly behind this there's
there's several
um I believe what was alluded to was the
process of having to go back through
fiscal to make adjustments
um from an administrative perspective uh
we we basically we we have to make that
determination a month approximately
about a month in advance of coming to
fiscal uh the reason that we were
requesting this was not necessarily
because of the administrative burden of
that but more so because uh our I.T
systems we have had scenarios where
um we've run out of money in one account
and we're not able to get through fiscal
fast enough because there may be a month
or three week delay
um in order in order to transfer those
funds so that was part of the reason
behind that request and we'll defer to
the committee's judgment on on what the
best direction is because I I also
recognize that you know we have to take
into account the public transparency
perspective it's just that behind the
scenes
um we do have some I.T challenges that
good to know of course question
representative erf her question
so not necessarily directly related to
that although that does concern anything
that's that separating things out but if
I understand correctly line 506 also
includes Meals on Wheels and Adult Day
yeah so 506 is um for CFI so things like
Adult Day supported housing
um non-medical Transportation I don't
believe Meals on Wheels
yes so also Meals on Wheels would be
included in that CFI line 506. so this
is
the counties providing meals on wheels
so how does this Meals on Wheels tie in
with all the other meals and wheels
so this would be the Medicaid waiver
service under
um this choices for Independence program
so a little bit different than how the
other Meals on Wheels programs are
determined they could be determined
based on interaction with servicelink
but this specifically is for the
Medicaid waiver CFI uh program I guess
what I'm trying to understand is these
are all meals and wheels programs being
delivered to people
are they the same people in different
programs sometimes how is this all
no yeah so some um to be on CFI you have
to be Medicaid eligible and then some of
the other programs that provide Meals on
Wheels there's an income um level and
um you're not Medicaid eligible so so I
understand that but how is that tracks
we don't you're not living this meals
I I would say that you know for CFI we
have Case Management Services that
really look at the assessed need of the
person and so
um you know I think we would be able to
figure out
you know if somebody again somebody not
on Medicaid wouldn't be able to access
these Meals on Wheels in 506 because
they have to have Medicaid to get CFI
the other way around so she said the
ones that are on Medicaid wouldn't be
able to get it but their way around
so you you've got three pots of money
here it sounds like at least I don't
know maybe there's more in this budget
question mark
no no in in the whole budget are there
we've encountered three places where
meals and wheels are so far just this
there there may be individuals accessing
meals through fundraising at the agency
level okay
but that wouldn't be
okay so for these three I'm just trying
to understand it so we're talking about
a lot of money right I mean
I don't know what that total is but it's
a lot
um I'm just curious how this is all
coordinated
do we really need all those pots of
money all that money that's in all those
pots or some of those pots duplicative
we the at the agency level they'll track
and transition people so if somebody's
been getting meals for a couple of years
through our older American psych
services and then they transition or
become eligible for Medicaid
um through the CFI program they're the
payer source for their meal would change
but they would continue to get the meal
they had always been get so you're
you're depending on the providers to
let me ask it this way do you have a
database a lot of people getting Meals
okay and you have any ability to
actually cross-check them to see if
to pull reports and combine the data to
to check and see if there may be a
transition do you ever do that
we do that we do do that on occasion
okay I'd be curious to see that cross
checks
Altman and I'm the bureau chief of the
Bureau of elderly and Adult Services
representative Stringham for a question
um following up
um yeah I I'm not sure 100 I want to
make sure I understood what you meant by
cap to County
um services so there's a maximum amount
of of uh funds available to support
nursing home uh bound patients at the
county level
is so
um let's say the counties end up having
20 percent more patients than they they
projected you would still be capped at
the same amount so essentially you would
have paid less per person or exactly
what does that mean sure so and and also
just to clarify so so these payments are
are for for the nursing facilities I
believe there's approximately 71 across
the state not not the County nursing
facilities
um so so the the 132 million that's in
the governor's recommended budget right
now that's the that's the the maximum
amount that the county would contribute
to this so basically on a monthly basis
the counties each make payment to DHHS
we take that we match it with the
federal dollars and draw those down
um for those payments um there are uh
the the mqip and pro share accounts that
that are to come those are supplemental
payments
um to the counties I can see
representative Earth is ready to talk
about that um but
um that so so those are the payments
that go to the County nursing homes I
think that's just an important
distinction to make here
thank you
representative Wallner for question
I just wondered if you could once again
why are the
I think you went over this but
the county cap is always for me at least
hard to really get hold of but why is
the are the figures in
the budget different from
um that is a great question
um I I I guess I would I would answer
with um please let me know what you
would like us to do with that we will
Rectify that and submit a change request
foreign
doubt that I the county Camp is always
interesting
and just to add to that I'll have you
know in discussions about House Bill 2
one of the first things that comes up is
the famous County Camp so it sounds like
we're touching on the tip of an iceberg
here and we understand and I think
that's been made very clear that we have
some work to do on that topic
and and our the the agency budget
request um that we submitted for the 24
and 25 biennia um that that that's based
on the two percent figures so the 129
million and 131
being approximate
um that that we had included there
um
now there are there are a couple of
um class nodes here
that that I I think are important just
to
um just to talk about the the first one
it was new for the current biennium
um and what that did was was essentially
if if there are funds left over we shall
make a lump sum payment we've we've
engaged just to make the committee aware
we have engaged with the federal
government on how this could work
because traditionally
um in order to draw down the federal
funds we have to have the service that
was provided this is a little different
and we're still trying to figure out
whether we can actually effectuate
um the intent of this original class
note we're still waiting to hear back
from the feds as to whether this is
feasible or not I hope to have some some
rectification on that issue here soon
representative erf for question so are
these notes new or were these in the
current budget as well these are in the
current budget for for this I apologize
I misspoke these are in the current
budget HP one operating budget today not
get that yeah but this is HP one but the
current budget biennium are they in that
one yes okay thank you
and and this language is is uh is
there is is that we're not allowed to
consider any of these class lines for
Budget reductions we can't transfer out
of this to to cover shortfalls in other
areas so
um okay
turning to account 2154 uh nursing
services
so this account is primarily
um 50 50 Medicaid they're in class 509
other nursing Services
um there are four hundred thousand
dollars of General funds that do not
have a federal match that are for LNA
Workforce Development
otherwise these are payments that are
made for a community in the Blind and
Cedar Crest and also I don't know if you
want to speak to that
yeah so Cedar Crest is our only
Intermediate Care Facility for kids that
are have a developmental or
intellectually disabled
um that need a higher level of care
medically
um so they have about I think they have
26 Feds that are dedicated
um for
um for ICF for children with
developmental disabilities that have
okay
so on page uh 2157
um these are these are the uh mqip
payments which also continue on to page
uh 937 in um in account uh 2161 and I'm
gonna ask Henry Littman just to come up
and give folks an overview just because
he's the resident expert here and I
won't pretend to be what I'm not so hang
on one second
foreign
okay
so probably good afternoon I've been
mourning usually um Henry Lipman the
Medicaid director uh
it might be a good just to provide a
high level of what we're looking at here
before we delve into the numbers
um see representative Earth's smiling
we've spent a few phone calls on this in
the past
um so
the system for paying for nursing
facilities is really comprised of three
key components there's a a rate a daily
rate
Which is less than the nursing homes
cost of providing the service
and then added to that for County
facilities
um and for
um non-county facilities the privates is
what we call a Medicaid quality
incentive payment
and that is the funding behind that
is a
um called the nfqa nursing facility
quality assessment
tax which is applied to the net Patient
Service revenues for a a prior period
um and that generates
dollars that allow us to draw a federal
match and so the the assessment that's
paid plus the federal match is then used
to make up some of the difference
between
what the nursing homes
um the payment so it's really if you
will daily rate plus M quip helps to
close that Gap
um
and so that's this part of a the budget
is the mqip which is the part that all
nursing facilities get to participate in
during the federal Public Health
Emergency
which is ending May 11th
um
there's been an enhancement to that
Federal match which the state has passed
on to providers that uh uh probably I
think the the current quarterly payment
will reflect the 6.2 percent
um the next quarterly payment this is
paid on a quarterly basis we'll we'll
reflect the five percent enhancement
then the following quarter will be two
and a half percent and then by year end
it'll be down to one and a half percent
and then it'll be back to that 50 50
match
so that's that's mqip
or our County facilities which tend to
um have a a different type of pyramix in
terms of the types of patients uh
there's also an additional payment
called Pro share which is later in the
budget but that's intended to fill in
more of the gap for the County nursing
facilities that being said the all three
of those payments do not necessarily
cover the full cost of of covering for a
Medicaid patient but that's sort of a
starting point I see representative yes
will you yield to questions yes your
knowledge is so interesting we could
listen to you all day but we do have a
question in between representative erf
for a question just a quick confirmation
you've told me this before this tax is
bed tax is is on nursing home days or
it's a nursing home revenues revenues
okay thank you it's based on net Patient
so the you know I think the the
estimates here are based on the you know
estimated
net Patient Service revenues that are
occur that occur and I think that when
it comes time to uh actually
the tax to be paid and the tax has to be
paid before the the match can be drawn
so there's a gap between the nursing
facilities putting out the dollars and
and then getting the payment we try to
keep that as short as possible by
coordinating very closely
um but there there is a little uh it's
typically days or not more than a couple
of weeks is kind of what we aim for
um
and so I guess the the numbers here
reflect sort of our best estimates now
how these numbers in in practice may
vary is that
um particularly the the pro share
payment because that sort of fills in
that third Gap is that
um nursing facilities
their rate
plus the the M grip plus the pro share
can be no higher than their Medicaid 100
costs and so
um if a rate increase is provided and
that's higher than their their cost
increase then
um there is that Gap what can be paid
potentially can shrink the reverse is
also true if the rate increases lower
than their cost then the Gap may
increase so we can fill in more of that
but I think you know last legislative
session there was a
a rate increase passed for nursing
facilities which
um you know we assured through a couple
different mechanisms that it would be at
least five percent it's been more than
that
in terms of the county facilities
anyways and and and the base rate for
all facilities but uh let me stop there
because it can get a little bit more
confusing as you go along but that's
actually hard to believe but yes uh any
questions or at this point
representative Stringham for a question
yeah I wonder uh what are roughly the
base daily rates that you're dealing
with uh and is there a difference by
county or by uh County within you know
by geographic area or uh private versus
County facility
so the the rates are set based on a
Medicaid cost report from a Medicaid
cost report so there are in the
reimbursement methodology that is part
of our state plan uh for example there
are some limitations on Capital costs
that uh it can't be more than
um 85 percent of the median or something
like that I don't have it memorized the
league full of spot page but generally
there's some controls so that that we're
not reimbursing costs that are
unreasonable if you will and so the the
rates are set on a
um
on a
you know completed cost report period
and and then our updated
um
twice a year
to reflect uh changes in Acuity and and
terms of how we set the base rate for
the facilities so it's it's more
variable based on the patient Acuity
patient illness burden if you will the
amount of nursing care that they need
Rehabilitation and so forth and so a
facility that accepts a higher case mix
would typically you would expect to see
have a higher rate because they have
costs to cover that more complex patient
mix
um thank you um in terms of if I
understand the Sam quick calculation
basically in order to access the federal
funds we have to put in 50 of the funds
and we're collecting those 50 percent of
the funds by charging a tax to the
nursing homes so they're paying the
money and then it's basically
reapportioned as a payment back to the
nursing home combined with the federal
uh matching portion does that sound
about right that's exactly right okay
and um
um
ballpark you know what percentage above
the base daily rate is at is that one
percent or is that ten percent fifty
percent
um well I think if the the budget is
around 200 and the total budget is uh on
the page for nursing facilities
so
I think if you just take this m quip
number and divide it by the total
Nursing Facility payments that will give
you that percentage I just don't have
that at the top of my head I can do that
calculation and send it to you but based
on
326 024 about a quarter thousand uh on
page 934 I think that would give you 20
percentage but I'll double check that
number
okay
ready for the next level
I think we in large measure in terms of
the the tax is what that's collector
actually generates the payment there's
no general fund
exposure there Pro share is the same
um and that the counties this one can be
the sort of two flavors of it that exist
that's representative erf is well aware
of from Hillsborough County that um the
majority of our nursing facilities
and sort of stepping back for a moment
back I think
we were sort of refined the method for
drawing
the match and we were able to increase
the amount of pro share available pretty
substantially for
um and then CMS made some adjustments to
how we could
do that which reduced it down some but
compared to where we were in 2017 we're
doing a better job in drawing Federal
money for for nursing facilities
there's two methodologies there's a
certified public expenditure methodology
which is the majority of our nursing
homes are on which is that when we
measure that gap of cost versus payments
in the aggregate that
CMS will pick up half of that and so
what we do there is present a recent
cost report usually we describe it as an
interim cost report and so if the gap
for a particular facility was three
million dollars then
um we would be able to draw a federal
match of 1.5 million no dollars change
hand other than presenting the our cost
and then the feds matching that that Gap
um by 50 percent during the the
Public Health Emergency and our next
payment will in 23 we'll have an extra
five percent on it
um
so that we'll get 55 as opposed to 50
but that that will that won't happen
again
um then and there's another
um approach which Hillsborough County
and two other counties had used at one
point uh because it was more
advantageous
um is an intergovernmental transfer
where similar to the tax the county has
to come up with uh dollars and make a
payment
um for for that uh to the state then the
state draws down a federal match to make
that
what's been interesting is during the
the
you know we've talked a lot about
Staffing shortages and the costs of
covet and the like that it has become
um more advantageous for all the nursing
facilities up to well say through 2022
at this point to be on the certified
public expenditure methodology because
costs have gone up much faster than than
rates
um we're working through something with
Hillsborough County now to try to get
them the most advantageous way of doing
it and that's still an open item which
uh I think the administration and the
leadership they're aware of but
so that depending on how that one goes
it may go through an intergovernmental
transfer or certified public expenditure
we're going to try hard to get the most
advantageous way
okay anything further Mr Lipton and that
no I I happy to answer any questions I
know it's a it's a little bit dense in
terms of working through and you know we
do have spreadsheets I know sometimes
that's easier for people to to follow
and be able to think about it um but
it's not not necessarily recommended
reading for everybody
so we'll proceed
um through the categories
my thought was to break it lunch uh 12
noon I don't know if that's going to be
um enough time for you to wrap up your
program and I know there are others here
that wish to speak I'm sure on this uh
particular topic but that's my thought
um so if we move on to
page 937 the CFI waiver program
eligibility
no no change in positions within this
um within this account here uh there we
we do have
um A in the class 74 a larger a couple
of contracts a key Pro contract and a
contract with Community Partners this is
uh
uh this um I don't know if you want to
speak to those
so
this is this department operates the
nursing facility level of care
determinations assignment of case
management agencies for individuals that
are coming on to the CFI program
um also the um like Nathan said in set
074 is our keeper contract which is a
screening for people who are nursing
home looking to be admitted to a nursing
home so screening for any
mental illness or developmental
disability to ensure that they're
appropriate to be at a nursing facility
and not in another level of care
um and then the contract with Community
Partners is to fund to full-time
eligibility coordinators
um that are housed via service link
representative erf for a question
so the CFI that's here is that the total
program or is that just a CFI as it
um this would be this the PSI program
kind of like administrative costs as far
as it's determining people's eligibility
for CFI so not the actual provision of
service but
um getting people enrolled in Medicaid
making sure they meet the CFI
eligibility
um and doing
um that Medicaid the medical eligibility
determination for the administrative
um on page 9 30 uh 938 still monetary
penalties
um our our legal team uh they actually
collect uh various penalties you'll see
a pretty dramatic uh decrease from our
contract line uh in safe field school
year 23.
um we we've adjusted that in 24 and 25
to make it a little bit more accurate
and appropriate
um and anytime we do receive penalties
we actually have to submit a plan to the
feds to receive approval and and we use
these dollars to make Nursing Facility
improvements and other related projects
um
on page
let's see here
so if okay so from there we will
actually be turning to page
1042 and in your
um
all right and then in your
your presentation the the coloring book
I I really like that phrase I think the
colors go well with that determinology
um it's we're actually on on page 12
right now
yep so so we'll come back to page 11 in
in the presentation in the PowerPoint
so if if we turn to to page uh 1042
um this is our this is our our DNA
account and we had talked about this
earlier with the dads rate
um in there uh which which would um
offset the the cost in 502 to allow us
to provide that three percent increase
to the existing rates
um I don't know if we want to discuss uh
this in more detail or are we are we
good there
it looks like we're all set okay
excellent uh on page uh 1043 this is uh
59.47
um we did have uh we did have a
conversion here uh you you will see an
increase in the number of personnel uh
we did convert a full-time uh temporary
position to a full-time authorized
position uh through the process that I
described earlier the indirect cost line
that was zeroed out there uh 040 that
was centralized within 9 500 within the
office of the commissioner we also added
one temporary position here in class 50
as well
um there are a couple of larger
contracts that are paid out of this
account and I'll also speak to those
yeah so we have a contract with the
University of New Hampshire Institute on
disabilities so they do a lot of work
with us in coming up with you know um
planning for our disability Community we
also have some money in there for
Guardianship Services so either through
the Office of Public guardian or
Tri-County Guardianship Services for
looks like representative Wallner for
question
obviously
um
under 102 the contracts have gone up
considerably
this was the um
the guardian service one million dollar
oh yes so so we previously had these
dollars in account of 41 14.
um I can tell you the name of that
yeah so the so we previously had these
dollars within the Bureau of Mental
Health Services
um within Guardianship Services in in
their class 102 and we and we moved
about a million dollars
um over into this account uh and Melissa
can speak to the rationale yeah it was
really to pay our fair share for the
guardianship slots that we that we um
have so we were able to move that money
over for us to have not only an
increased uh rate for
um the Office of Public Guardian but
also increased number of slots for
guardianships and what was the previous
account you mentioned it's
4114 so so you'll see approximately I'm
just doing some back of the envelope
math of approximately 850 000 reduction
foreign
and and those were 100 General funds
on page 1044 uh 7016 account acquired
brain disorder services
um we
uh do you want to speak to the sure so
this is another 1915 C waiver program
that the bureau
administers with our providers in the
community for people with an acquired
brain disorder so individuals who
sustained a a brain injury after the age
of 22 and are financially and medically
eligible at a level of care that would
meet nursing home level of care but want
so some of the services would be
Residential Services day Services if
they need environmental modifications or
vehicle modifications
supported employment technology Services
representative irf for question
so there's some pretty large increases
here I'm not Muslim
misunderstanding
um the these are these are based on on
the projections for for the services
that are needed that that we have today
and and that's where those figures came
from
so more people in the programs so what
that yes that is my understanding is
that
I would I would say that um when you
look in I think in the budget briefing
Book You'll see
um I don't know if there's a much of an
increase but we're we're we have an
eligibility person within BDS that is
seeing an increase
um even in this uh years calendar year
for folks for services on on this waiver
so we're seeing more people that have an
acquired brain injury that are aren't
necessarily better served on the
developmental Services waiver that their
needs are different the Staffing's
different the the recreational services
are different for people with the with
the brain injury
representative walner for a question so
approximately how many people are on the
on this um
are on the brain
this area the brain disorder
so for
um
State fiscal year 23 it was 292 people
um we're looking at 297 for 24
representative Stringham for a question
yeah I was just wondering if you color
this in a little bit I mean we're
looking at a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per per case and these are
people if I read the note that are
already Medicaid eligible so they have
access to some medical services that
would not come out of this this budget
so and
um you know I understand you know some
degree of Home refurbishing or things
like that but that it just sounds like a
much much bigger number
yeah a lot of the services that are
provided under this Weaver are also like
a an assisted living residential service
so
um if they can't live independently
um in in an apartment or in the
community there are
um uh beds that are
um paid for under the waiver for
residential services
which drives the cost higher
okay thank you
so the increase in numbers of people the
percentage changes there are not even
close to the percentage changes in the
would it be acceptable if if we get an
analysis together and and send that to
the committee
that would be awesome all right thank
you
representative walner are you or
question okay
representative for a question just a
quick question like a big picture look
at this category
um would I be correct in that providing
services to people
in their home would be more affordable
than the services in a institution a
nursing home yes absolutely so the the
cost of serving most people in the
community is less than institutional
care so
those totals you gave roughly 300 people
is does that include all
um
persons who
fall in this category or could there be
other patients that are in nursing
facilities no it would just be these
okay we're ready for the next category
okay
um and then if you turn to page uh 10 45
uh this is 7110 account this is the
children in home support waiver
yeah so this is another 1915 C waiver
that supports
um children
um
age 21 or under that lives at home with
their family and again there's some
level of care determinations that need
to be made but really it's it's it's a
waiver to help support kids and their
families to stay at home again rather
and um representative Wallner for a
question I just I wondered how many
um
so for State fiscal year 22 it was 456
um individuals
um for were projecting for this fiscal
year
um people being served
welcome representative Stringham for a
question
um yeah just just my understanding that
the disability uh developmentally
disabled support for children was
largely provided through the school
system
so how does this coordinate with that or
um do I misunderstand no yeah it is a
collaborative kind uh it's a
collaborative effort between the school
system
um sometimes dcyf is involved as well
um and us at BDS as far as you know
who's eligible for what type of service
so if a school determines that their
education needs can be met despite their
developmental disabilities then we're
engaged in providing some Services
versus the schools being
um the ones providing that service
they've said do your payments then go to
the school system or direct a provider
or right yeah nope it goes directly to
the area agency system who then um
distribute the money to the the families
okay
I think we're
ready to proceed okay
um if we turn to page uh 10 10 46
um
yes uh account uh 7013
[Music]
um
these These are the contracts that we
have with the area agencies that are
reflected here it's 100 General funds
for for I don't know if there's any
we look good okay
um moving on excuse me uh to 7167
Medicaid compliance
um two positions you will notice an
increasing in class 10 uh two positions
were previously unfunded in the prior
biennium that's why you're not seeing an
FTE increase on page 1047 but only an
increase in the class 10 and I don't
know if there's any other questions on
looks good uh unemployment compensation
I will skip over that on 10 47.
and then that brings us to page
it it brings us to page 11 we're
actually going backwards in the in the
presentation here
account 3674 the infant toddler program
um this is funded through Federal idea
act funds
and we we also pay for
um uh dollars come out of here for Area
Agency contracts as well
if there's any questions there that this
particular
account is a hundred percent federal
funds
okay
uh 36.75 the social services block grant
DD
um this is a there there are two
individuals that are included within
this account we have a couple of
contracts that are paid out of here with
Waypoint Partners in Health
I don't know if there's any any
questions on this account and these are
ssbg dollar or social services block
all right
um page 1050 account 3676 special
Medicaid services
um this was actually formally account
5191 uh just if you look at at the prior
opera or the current operating budget
you may not be able to match it up
um this this accounting unit was moved
and that's why it has been renumbered uh
no significant changes on the Personnel
front
here
um
okay on page 1051 we do have out of the
56 1 class line um that is 100 General
funds that is paid out of there and we
we have a contract and I don't know if
um
culinary clinics which included in in
fiscally year 22 we had 30 different
clinics
um and 12 clinics for complex care
coordination so that's Healthcare that's
nursing consultation it could be
nutrition feeding swallowing programs
mental health consultations and on
unpaid costs
and and the um we we do have Medicaid
dollars in here those are the that's the
federal funding source that you see
there
at the bottom of page 1051 we have 3677
early intervention
um we also have a contract line here
that that is used to pay for the area
agency contracts
um and again you'll you'll start to see
a theme within within many of the
accounts within the department where we
have single contracts that are paid out
of uh multiple uh streams of funding
okay
um all right if you
let's see here
turning to pay uh turn into page 1052
there there is a class note there
um the funds in in 502 do not lapse for
and
thank you both very much very detailed I
think that was a very thorough go
through and we're all fully cognizant of
how much time and effort you put into
these presentations I know we see an
incredible amount of effort and time
just in the last two hours but we don't
see behind the scenes but we're still
very much aware of how much goes into
each and every square inch of these
presentations so thank you both
I do just want to add as a follow-up
from the from my support back there um
as far as the um the meals we serve last
fiscal year we served one million six
hundred and thirteen thousand four uh
one million 613
740 meals with just our uh money through
the contracts so that doesn't include
the agency fundraising meals things like
that so just wanted to add that
real good and I know there are a few
other uh follow-up items too if you need
any um
I'm sure you have notes on those but we
do as well so that'll be good to get
those from you anything uh to close out
this particular presentation
representative Stringham some about the
discussions made me real hungry I'm not
sure why
maybe we can get you a meal a home
okay thank you both very much now a
thing as though it's almost a 5 of 12.
I'm curious as to who in the audience
would like to come up and talk related
to this particular work session on this
no one Gina I thought so
[Laughter]
so
yes I if everyone's agreeable to that I
think that would be good and the timing
would work out very well I know uh
all this talk on meals and wheels has
made some of us hungry but we're
I think that would work out fantastic so
welcome Gina you're always welcome
just be sure to make sure the
microphone's on and very close to you so
Home Care hospice and palliative care
Alliance of New Hampshire and our
advocacy affiliate the granite state
home health and hospice Association I
just wanted to follow up this morning's
conversation with one with one point
um in the uh the budget book I believe
it's on page 11.
uh underneath at the very bottom of the
page under prioritized need it says that
DHHS does not have a wait list for those
requesting Services Under the CFI waiver
and additional funds are required to
meet increased caseload needs and access
to Services I think it's important to
understand that I would agree there's no
wait list for people requesting services
that one can apply to CFI and be
determined eligible that does not mean
that and that you're going to get
services
and I think that's just important for
the committee to understand as I
mentioned last week the utilization rate
in fiscal year 2022 was on average 66
percent of the authorized services that
that clients needed and depending on the
service that you need in CFI it could be
much less
you know could be about 50 percent of
your services if you're new to CFI
I think it would you should talk to the
independent case managers they will tell
you that they cannot Place see they
cannot arrange CFI services
home care agencies cannot take on new
clients and that's just the reality and
I think that um
Amy Moore was with me last week from a
century In-Home Care her agency turns
away 40 to 50 clients a month from CFI
because they do not have the staff to
provide services so I just want to
clarify that I would agree that
additional funds are required to
increase access to services and that's
what we spoke about last week when I
came in with the requested rates and
once again we're looking to have those
rates raised
to be comparable with the title 20 and
3B rates so I think
um that's I hope that you'll take a look
at that presentation again and
specifically Helen in on those rates and
with that
unless there are questions I'll let you
go to lunch
any questions for MS baucus
okay thank you so much for your time
thank you
any further yes
absolutely is it Mr Cahoon yes
um thank you madam chair my name is Gary
Cahoon I'm here representing the New
Hampshire Association a residential care
homes and
um Gina just talked about unprovided
Services services that were authorized
but not provided because the providers
weren't available
to a degree that can be Quantified
for CFI Home Services
the same situation exists with CFI
residential care services but it can't
be Quantified in the same way
and the reason is and I I think I try to
make this point last week but I just
want to be sure that I was clear
the services are not authorized until a
bet is found
so if there is a CFI client who the case
management team decides is best served
in a residential care setting
they then look for a residential care
bed but that residential care service is
not
authorized until the bet is found so a
hundred percent virtually of authorized
services are met but it's not because
100 of the need is met nowhere close to
100 of the need I suspect in fact that
the unmet need is greater than it is for
home care services
but there's only anecdotal evidence to
us to
understood thank you for that thank you
very much any questions for Mr Cahoon
while he's here okay thank you Mr
all right anyone else uh wanting to say
something or contribute to this
particular work session
all right with that I'm going to uh
close it and then we will reconvene this
committee will reconvene at one o'clock
in order to work on House Bill 527 is
there anything further yes
yes in 104 yes right room 104.
sorry
foreign
noticed on House Bill 2 5 27 relative to
Medicaid reimbursement rates for certain
assisted living facilities so uh before
we begin I just want to give a brief uh
legislative history of the bill so we
all know where we are
the bill came to finance first so this
is not from a second commit City it came
directly to finance it had a public
hearing on the 9th of February and then
a division work session also on the 9th
of February
um
or rather I guess on the on the 27th is
that right Mr Ripple
it looks like a yes okay on the on the
27th of February was the first work
session so then that leads us to this
work session today
and where we left off from the previous
work session is an amendment that was
brought to us by the two Bill sponsors
one of which is here today that is
hyphen zero four five six H does
everybody have a copy of that I think
that will be the focal point of our
just want to uh it's
actually not on the dock it online
so it must just be within the committee
are you making copies Mr Ripple oh thank
you very much I appreciate that
um so that will be the focal point of
our work session today is that Amendment
as I understand it a lot of new
information has been discovered upon the
initial
introduction of the bill and so it's
important that we consider this
amendment before moving forward
so uh once Mr Ripple comes back we'll
hear I think first approach most
appropriately from representative
Horrigan who is a sponsor of the bill
and a sponsor of the amendment so if
you'd like to make yourself comfortable
Mr Horrigan we will be hearing you
momentarily
prior to hearing the representative are
there any initial thoughts or comments
or questions or directions we want to go
from the members of the committee
and just um again because that
you could perhaps start representative
Horrigan but know that not everybody has
a copy at this particular point where
copies provided at the tail end of the
works at the public hearing yes uh in
any case yeah I'm sure some members do
have this started with uh HP 527 a
request to expand their Medicaid rates
uh for assisted living facilities small
assisted living facilities 16 beds or
less
happy to get closer I think to the
microphone
that's better thank you
uh
as a result of the public hearing and
the folks sitting behind me here we
learned some things that prompted us to
make an amendment which is what you're
looking at today
but the only change was to
identify the license that particularly
applied to my constituent which was the
HP or Hep 804
uh so that's what was added when the
amendment was
created
527 is still a request to increase the
rates on the assisted living facilities
for 16 beds or less 50 Medicaid
occupancy
and then
as it applies to that specific license
and one of the things I learned at the
public hearing was that these they
weren't
quite a number of licenses and they are
applied based on the
as I understand it the level of care
that the facility provides
but the issue here was 16 beds or less
50 Medicaid occupancy and uh because my
constituents
Assisted Living care facility is an 804
we're specifically requesting for a rate
increase for the rate up for the 804.
okay thank you representative so to sort
of get our bearings here in this work
session it's pretty clear that the
original language of the bill is not
going to work no matter what
primarily because the phrase and the
term small assisted living facilities is
not defined in the law and thus your
Amendment
is the purpose of that was to Define
what your constituent was looking for
correct representative erf for a
question
so that license it's ep84 that
is specific to the size as well
thank you for the questions I understand
it 804 specifically refers to by
constituents
assisted living facility
I agree with that but I think it covers
many more than your constituents I
believe it does too but I do not
know personally that I can't answer that
question and say yes it does okay
there's probably somebody here who can
answer that but I don't believe it's
size specific I think it's more
functional specific correct that's my
understanding okay
now representative also uh we have
you've heard testimony at our previous
work session uh from somebody who had
mentioned that if we're going to raise
the rates for one we should raise it for
all
and that would include everybody under
this particular licensee and if we were
to go that route that would
substantially change the fiscal note for
example and the bill in general do you
want to expand on that
foreign
my constituent I
don't want to predict what the finance
people would do I know it would
significantly increase the bottom line
there
because as I understand it the rates
vary depending on the level of the
license
uh in the size of the facility I'm not
quite sure how that works uh but I do
believe that if
they were to increase the rates it would
incorporate
more than my constituents facility
and that 10.5 I think as I understand it
as I interpret it it would be all
assisted living facilities with 16 beds
or less
however many there are
and I think that's what a 10.6 million
comes off
because the request I think works out
through about 3 500 roughly a month
41 000 a year
times whatever number of facilities I
think is how that 10.6 million dollars
came up
representative Stringham for a question
um yeah my understanding was that
um you know this daily rate is is a
standard service provided by
State and I don't know if anybody here
that can talk about it from DHHS so
therefore basically it would require a
structural change in the way that the
law is set up and perhaps even
negotiating uh uh with CMS or the
federal government I believe in order to
um
um you know set up different
classifications and have different
classification rules for for providing
the same service
um and um uh at least I think that's
kind of where we were toward the end of
the the last session that we had
um so
um if you're providing the same service
whether it's 90 Medicaid or one percent
uh Medicaid it would have the same rate
per day for that particular service for
whatever facility that applies to
whether it's you know 804 805.
um and um and you know I know you're
doing a great job supporting your
constituents and and yeah and you're
you're learning about this at the same
rate that we are so but is there
anything
um you know first of all that that I've
said that is inconsistent with what you
understand and you know I hope that uh
if there are people from the Department
that could further clarify that or
confirm that that we could get to that
direction too thank you my understanding
okay any other questions for the
representative
all right thank you so much
representative for coming and
rescheduling taking the time for us
appreciate that Mr Ripple we could just
one more copy of that Amendment over
here that would be fantastic okay uh
next to uh testify on the bill
did
um
from the Department of HHS did you wanna
come up I know I myself have a couple of
questions I'm sure others do as well if
you're comfortable with that
foreign
if you could just state your name for
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Rob Berry I'm
general counsel to the division of
Medicaid with New Hampshire Department
of Health Team services
I'm Christy Roy with rate setting for
the Department of Health and Human
Services
thank you very much I don't know if you
have any initial thoughts on the bill
however I myself am very curious in
terms of this classification of Hep 804
how many facilities in New Hampshire
fall under that classification sure so
the department is here to be helpful uh
to this process I I did want to note
that the Department's initial fiscal
analysis assumed that everybody would go
to the 115 dollar rate in the initial
bill so that would be Hep 804 and 805s
um so I just want to throw that out
there that that is a high
amount at the moment and can be adjusted
our recommendation from the Department's
perspective is to uniformly increase the
rate by a certain percentage to be
decided by this committee
um across all three levels of care
that's our recommendation and we can
provide some idea of what that might
look like based on certain percentages
but to get back to your original
question about how many Hep 804
facilities there are I am doing some
rough math so I I do want to couch that
now keep in mind that not all are going
to have Medicaid
individuals within that facility as well
so
understood representative Wallner for a
question
yes I I was wondering where where would
CFI they're under choice for
Independence so they're mixed in with
the other bills that are hurt for
choices for Independence I believe
okay thank you
representative erf for a question
what is the third license that you
referred to there's
80485 and well 805 is supported
residential care and that has both
levels of of the other Acuity levels so
that encompasses
um dementia level one and dementia level
two and then uh the AGP 804s are just
the standard Residential Care assisted
living facility okay so 805 has two sub
if you will and each one of them has a
different rate
yes that's correct okay and if we did a
percentage
it would get pretty
phenomenal once you included those other
ones wouldn't it or did you include all
the did you include those both those
under 805. we included everything so
that the fiscal no analysis we worksheet
analysis we did
um took every assisted living facility
804 805 regardless of the level of care
and just bump the rate to 150 I believe
it was so that's that's the top end okay
so you didn't do the percentage
calculation you just said would you
which won't work correct
you can't set them all the same rate can
you
you could we don't think it would make a
lot of sense given the
um
the nature of the uh care that's
provided let me ask a question a
different way what's the ratio of the
three right now from top to highest to
lowest isn't it like a two or three to
one
So currently as of uh July 1st 2022
the number in the Hep 804 for Medicaid
beds is uh 89.35 of Medicaid eligible
individuals dementia level one is 1.62
for the population and dementia level 2
is 7.22 percent
way more than three to one like five to
one maybe so roughly yeah I'm not very
good with math so I'll defer to Christy
over here
most of the um the Assisted Living are
on
Venture level generally that would be
nursing care above and beyond the
Assisted Living so most of the
population is that standard rate that is
the 115 rate
that we were talking about I understand
that but if you're reciting them
proportionally the top rate would be up
around the 700 and something dollar or
eight hundred dollar
based on what he just ran off there
oh no he was talking about the
percentage of
um beds so he was saying 90 of beds are
oh my question is what are the current
rates oh okay I apologize the current
rates
so the current rates are the 56.88 for
the standard care
84.74 for dementia 1 and 9541 for
dementia 2. oh okay okay
and for clarification what I gave us the
percentage of the population I've got
you okay
so roughly two to one from heideloft
not even that but still
okay representative talerski for a
question and then representative norgren
my question was answered I wanted
clarification on the first fiscal note
thank you
pardon me thank you
um so the fiscal note I have is 2 8 is
that the current fiscal note or do we
have a new fiscal note with it that's it
okay all right thank you
often we've had competing fiscal notes
I think salsa
representative norgren you're all set
yes thank you oh perfect all right okay
so now expanding on what we talked about
this is changing rates in one
various relatively small area of DHHS
does that make sense relative to all the
other rates across the I think it's a
I will note though that we do anticipate
um the governor's budget the 3.1 percent
would apply to assisted living
facilities and there may be some other
bills out there
um in the Senate if I'm not mistaken
that do uh direct the department to
increase rates as well
representative Stringham so um you know
part part of the bill and I'm not sure
about the amendment but talked about
um having different rates for different
facilities based on percent Medicaid so
not necessarily applying to
not necessarily applying to every
incidence of
um of you know what would be the
non-dementia or standard care
is that something that if we wanted to
do could be implemented without going
back to CMS
or
no
um so in order to collect a federal
match the rules for standard state plan
Medicaid would be we have to public
notice before that goes into place
and then we have to do a state plan
Amendment within the quarter that it
goes into place and then of course they
have to approve it so that's generally
how it would have to work
um with this particular rate it's all
it's a waiver service so it's on the
waiver and um my understanding of the
methodology that's currently in the
waiver is that it was set at a base rate
as a point in time and then adjusted by
a Market Basket inflation Factor but
then there's a budget neutrality taken
from it and that's
my understanding of how the waiver rates
are written in the waiver but it would
need an amendment for changing the
methodology
um so
um you know based on that I think your
suggestion is if we wanted to make an
adjustment in here we'd have to make an
adjustment that would apply to everybody
receiving these Services
um and and
um in the standard bucket we could
adjust all three buckets or we could
adjust just one correct but not
differently for different institutions
based on
some pairs payer split or whatever
correct the rate is a service base rate
so as long as it's the same service it
would be the same rate so verification
would be if there was an additional
service
a rate differential is allowable thank
you
okay and just to piggyback on what he
just said if we were to do exactly that
the fiscal note on the original Bill
dated 2823
is okay it's good for that description
if this committee decided to bump
everybody's rate up to 115 a day for
regardless of the level of service that
fiscal note is accurate yes meaning for
everyone meaning 48 that that are
licensed under Hep they would include he
p805 as well and a5s would be more than
48 okay great representative Weiler for
a question then representative erf
thank you madam chair
we presume that if we increase Medicaid
rates that the federal government which
pays 50 percent will match it
again it has to follow the process so I
couldn't speak on behalf of the federal
government but the process is standard
is first we have to public notice we
have to apply for that they have to
approve of the methodology and then yes
then they would accept there is an
opportunity they could say no it's too
big an increase that's that's correct do
we know what other states get do they do
they have different rates than we do yes
they do I think I
I thought I submitted that last time
um so
with
we typically look at
um other local
States and I've pulled for this and I
pulled Massachusetts that 106.76 Rhode
Island is at 78 Vermont has three tiers
which range from
6107 to 84 46.
and Connecticut is a
facility-based rate so they actually
look at every provider's cost report the
median is 89.53 in Connecticut the mean
is 97.29
. so we're lower than almost all the
other northeast states that's correct
thank you
representative erf
so just clarify what you just said did
at least one of those states have one
rate for all three
yes Massachusetts and Rhode Island have
the same rate any level of care
so do states have different levels of
care than the three that we talked about
so well they could Define it differently
so we are defining it as a dementia
level one and a dementia level two so
they could have for example we also have
the behavioral health of Behavioral
Health rate was in an assisted living
facility
then there could be another rate there
or so it would depend on how that state
defines it
so how did we so what about the what's
our Behavior Health rate or don't we
okay so does that come into a different
license it's a special contract here's
where things get muddy I suppose so that
was a special contract when there was a
Behavioral Health crisis that they moved
individuals from New Hampshire hospital
into nursing facilities and assisted
living facilities I don't know if if
everyone was part of that
um but it was it was handed to us um
there was a rate of 289 12 that was for
those few beds and it's a contracted
rate it ends in May
are there any more rates that we're not
aware of
um for assisted living yes for
residential care there are not any more
rates the the three main rates are the
rates here
the 289-12 behavioral health is a
special contracted rate for a temporary
time okay so some states have constant
rates across the three let's call them
standard pseudo standard
some states have variable rates like we
do does the department have any
recommendation as to like why did we
choose three separate rates and how what
was our methodology for coming up with
these ratios
so my understanding of the methodology
and this predates my time in the
department but my understanding of the
methodology is again that there was a
point in time standard set they did have
um
I believe there was a company that came
in to look at and rebasing all of the
CFI rates and then at that time that's
when the rates were determined as far as
the additional levels the 805 facilities
I believe are the only ones that qualify
for the level one and level two dementia
rates because they have another they
have added rules with additional medical
requirements and that's why they have
the two additional dementia level rates
that 804 facilities don't have that that
rule in additional medical requirement
so would the department consider
the absolute difference to be
appropriate or would they consider the
percentage difference to be appropriate
if and if the base rate was to be
changed and the and the assumption is
they're not going to help it won't be
constant at that point would they would
would it be just a whatever the rate
whatever the number is now the
difference in dollars just if you just
add those is that appropriate to
calculate the differences between the
levels of service or is it more probably
do the percentage-based calculation is
she's not the math guy why are you
looking at him yeah but he speaks on
behalf of the department I just
calculate rates
um
well I would if it were me on a personal
level I would consider the additional
requirement is nursing care and I would
not be comfortable having the same rate
for all three levels of care but I'm not
saying that on behalf of the department
no no but that's not even my question
but that's not my question I I get that
but right now there's a difference
between one two and three there's a
dollar difference and there's a
percentage difference and I'm just
trying to understand if we increase the
base
but it just makes sense to just keep the
same dollar differences forward it makes
sense to
do percentage differences just in terms
of costs I'm assuming that's sort of
what you have what you're looking at
with these rates
kind of
they were they were cost based at one
point in time um and the Market Basket
inflation factor which I mentioned so
that's applied is a cost based inflation
Factor Allowed by CMS
um I would
I would suggest a percentage is probably
adequate
um again that's
because those additional levels are
nursing care and we all have heard about
the many additional costs regarding
nursing at the time
represent representative hole for a
question
these questions
which of those three is probably the
biggest need and would you have a
percentage increase that's higher for
one particular right you have the option
of scaling them by Dollar you have the
option on scaling them by percentage you
have the option right potentially of
scaling them differently based on demand
and need for services if that's the case
so I guess it depends on how you would
you know Define what the biggest need is
um you know by far the Hep 804s which is
the standard assisted living facility
have the larger population the two
dimensional levels are are smaller
populations by a pretty significant
number and I gave those numbers earlier
uh where nearly 90 actually 89 if you
round down I suppose percent of our CFI
clients are in the standard residential
care where we only have you know
1.62 and the dementia level one and
seven point two two percent in dementia
level two so I don't know if that's
getting at what you're looking at uh
looking for so I'm looking at secondary
factors like vacancies for Staffing
positions right some of the other things
you're trying to meet right unmet right
waiting lists on beds those things are
directly impacted by the resources
available to hire staff and if you well
if you can't find the staff that's a
different we can't solve that issue but
if you were to change the reimbursement
rate you might be able to bring in more
staff for a particular need so right
percentage-wise
is the standard care right have the
biggest waiting list percentage-wise or
is it dementia one two right so I have
to bring that back sorry for the uh loud
uh I have to bring that back to um the
CFI administrator to get a sense there
um that was not a question I thought of
prior to this but I can certainly look
into that for the committee and get back
up items but I'm sure we'll get those
and absolutely thank you very much I see
uh Mr Cahoon here and I also see Miss
Horrigan here would either of you like
to come forward and speak on House Bill
527.
okay Mr Cahoon is the highest bidder
home I'm here representing uh Hampshire
Association of Residential Care Homes
um I would have been here representing
uh Friendship Manor as well
which was the home that my wife and I
ran for 37 years
um Friendship Manor would really love
this bill
um because we were an 804 home we were
about 90 to 95 percent Medicaid
and we close in May because we couldn't
hire anyone
um
so
but that does not necessarily mean that
that I think that this bill as it is is
the way that we should go forward
um the
there are a number of things I'd like to
say um there was a document distributed
last week
with the rates of neighboring states
the document's not quite complete okay
for example Rhode Island is down there
as a single rate Rhode Island actually
has three rates okay and the three rates
and and that's as of
um
just about a year ago February of 2022.
um the three rates are 78 dollars for
what they call Basic care and then they
have two enhanced rates one is 113 a day
and the other is 136 dollars a day
I actually have a couple of copies of
that if you'd like them I don't know if
you would or not
um that would be great if we could and I
think representative hole has a question
but it's probably related to that you've
already answered my question if you
could provide those rates in a document
all right they from they're from this
43-page document from the state of Rhode
Island about how it your rates uh an
individual's rate but that's page 16
from this document
um there's nothing down there for the
state of Maine now Maine has an
extensive
um Residential Care program or Assisted
Living Program
um
it's a little bit more complicated than
ours but we are our association uh and
New Hampshire Healthcare are working on
getting the rates from Maine
so as soon as we get those we will
forward them along to you
um
the other thing I wanted to point out it
was on the document that was distributed
again last week
that includes the rates in other states
um it does also include our rates
for the basic care dementia 1 and
dementia 2.
there is really no tie between
the rate and the license okay
um
Hep 804s are the bulk of oh I'm not even
sure that's true there are a lot of CFI
people in Hep 804s but there are a lot
of people at the basic rate in Hep 805s
as well
so the dementia rate is not per se an
805 rate
people who are receiving the dementia
rate in 804 homes but not very many
how these rates came about the question
was asked about 20 years ago the state
DHHS undertook a pilot program
to Pilot rates for dementia care
dementia care was becoming very much of
an issue at that time and three homes
participated in the in the uh I believe
initially in the pilot program
only two of those homes are still in
business okay uh those two homes are uh
the unit Deerfield
and pine Rock Manor and Warner
um when the
on the program ended
um I don't know what happened or what
how the decision was made but the
decision was made not to extend those
rates but the people who were in the
program were allowed to continue
charging those rates
so for about 20 years only two for two
or three providers were allowed to
charge the dementia rate
on July 1st of 2021 again there were
only two providers they were the unit
deer field and
um the uh
Pine Rock manner
as of July 1st 2022 there are 12
providers
so at that some time in the last year
and a half
the state decided
I'm not sure why but the state decided I
know that Wendy Altman who was here this
morning was some somewhat behind that
because you thought that made sense uh
to ex to expand that
availability of the dementia rates and
so that was done in the last year and a
half I know that there are actually at
least a couple of others that have been
added since July 1st of 2022 so now it's
probably a little bit north of 12
facilities
um
yeah so
I I yeah I guess basically that's what I
have to say uh the
I I think the concept of 527 is pretty
flawed uh I think that people need to
look at the rates across the board
we probably need to make more use of the
dementia rate
um
and
as an industry CFI ResCare needs more
than a 3.1 percent
because it is a disappearing industry
um
of the
uh
I have another document here excuse me
um
yeah on July 1st 2022 there were 554 CFI
ResCare clients in beds
[Music]
and only 49 of those were receiving the
um
the either dementia one or dementia 2
rates
so that's roughly nine percent are
receiving that rate
so even though more providers are now
signing up for this so the access is
still extremely Limited
um and
you know if something isn't done
uh there's a genuine General decline in
the number of CFI ResCare clients so
something isn't done that will disappear
as an option and it really takes a
structural change
which is why our association has asked
for an 80 a day basic rate what what is
done with the dementia rates we haven't
actually gotten into but they should
probably be maintained and increased a
bit as to how we came to those dementia
rates I believe the it's simply been a
percentage increase over 20 years that
was not really a study done in any
recent time to decide this is an
appropriate dementia rate so
it's just you know three percent a year
or whatever it was
thank you representative erf for a
question so I think you kind of hinted
at that when you said this isn't the
right vehicle
so we've been talking about rates
relative to other states specific to
this right but now look more broadly at
all rates
in terms of ratios between states is it
gen so let's talk about tech Rhode
Island there's we're higher than ours
are there rates across the board
generally higher than ours or is this
okay so it's not just that we're low
here relative to Rhode Island we're
probably proportional to Rhode Island by
some Factor
approximately yes okay I'm not familiar
certainly with all the rates okay well
of course there are a lot of rates I bet
you're generalizing but yeah I believe
our nursing home rates in general are
lower than the other New England states
okay thank you very much Mr Cahoon
appreciate your input and all the work
you've done at friendship manner is that
what it's called friendship matter
friendship manner
thank you madam chair Kate Horgan uh
with the New Hampshire Association of
counties I would agree with Mr Calhoun
we probably need rate increases across
the board as you all know as members of
your delegation
County nursing homes and the Health Care
system in general are in crisis
Hillsborough County for example has over
a hundred nurses vacancies in their
facility counties are closing beds
because we can't afford to get people to
fill those positions rate increases need
to happen across the board uh I'm happy
to take any questions but that our
position has not changed with the
amendment
representative erf for a question
so how would you increase rates across
the board I have an answer for you
representative uh so we uh with a bunch
of stakeholders have been working with
Senator Rosenwald on what
effective use of rates increases would
be without
using a making it a impossible number
for us to get I will say the work we've
done at the nursing home level would
require a 15 increase
those numbers are going to be in Senate
Bill 86
um and it will cover all of the rates in
covered under Medicaid
including DD as well
I knew you'd have a good answer thank
you
representative tulerski for a question
thank you I just want to clarify Senate
Bill 86 is that a 15 increase across all
of the licenses that is just for nursing
homes just for nursing that's okay thank
you
representative Stringham for a question
did you have a recommendation for the
facilities that are under this bill uh I
am sure it is included in that list but
I don't remember what the number is off
the top of my head representative
Stringham but I could look that up
quickly and get it to you before I leave
today thank you
okay real good all set thank you thank
you for your input I know you did send
us information when this bill was first
in a work session yes uh the committee
had asked me how many uh assisted living
facility beds The Three Counties who
provide assisted living facilities uh
have and it's under 50 beds for
Rockingham Cheshire and Merrimack but
those beds have never been filled more
thank you thank you
Mr
Oh by all means
just be sure to speak clearly to the mic
as we have an audience on YouTube for
all posterity okay
there was a question about the waiting
list and and uh attorney Barry said that
he would look into it and see if he
could get back to you with those numbers
I am going to predict that he won't be
able to I'm sorry not because he's not
competent because he certainly is but
but because those numbers certainly
aren't simply aren't kept uh as I
the department tracks these things
through authorizations Residential Care
beds and CFI are not authorized until
the case manager involved finds a bed
so and I confirmed all this within the
last week or two with uh staff from beas
they cannot tell you what the unmet need
is okay they know that it's substantial
but they haven't got statistics that
will reflect it
thank you okay representative Stringham
for a question Mr Cahoon if you're uh
just a quick interested in taking them
and then representative hole do you
think it would be an an improvement to a
system to a first first approve somebody
for for eligibility for a facility
before you try to match them with a
place and is that something that could
be done
the way the way it works um
there's an application process for the
authorization okay and on the
application process it's divided into
two sections one is for home care and
the other is for residential care
um
and
the case manager as I understand it uses
this document and if there are home care
services that they're seeking
authorization for but there are no
providers available there's a box that
they can check that says no providers
available
for residential care there's the same
thing there's a box that they can check
that says no providers available
but they don't make the initial
application for residential care because
if they do then they're not eligible for
Home Care
so if they can't find a bed the person
is without Services altogether
so typically they make the application
initially for home and health Home Care
Home Services and when a bed is found
they transfer the eligibility to
Residential Care
okay
representative hole
to your point that the data is not
collected
can you foresee a way that the those
patients are those individuals seeking
care
somehow are tracked at least in a I made
the request but I don't
it hasn't opened a case so we'd at least
have that information available the
people I talked to two weeks ago um
they'll remain nameless here for the
sake of the guilty
um well uh I said they would they would
consider that she said yeah that we need
to do something here to track these and
I'm not exactly sure how they would do
it again I can give you all kinds of
anecdotal evidence one of the ladies who
was here this morning is the uh is the
owner of a case management service
and she told me last week that she has
four clients who have been waiting for a
residential care bed for over a year
okay
representative ER
I just want to understand that statement
you made about
you're waiting for Home Care
until you get home care
like they don't count that once you get
that but then they immediately apply for
residential care and then they counted
that you're waiting for residential care
no because they if they make the
application for eligibility for
residential care they're ineligible for
home care so I I I get that so so they
apply for home care right right and then
now they just not really waiting because
they don't count it as waiting until
they actually get a home care what
typically happens is if the case manager
believes this client really needs
Residential Care they continue to look
for a residential care bed and when they
find the Residential Care bid and that
person is accepted they change the
eligibility status
the eligibility status is not usually
changed until the day that they actually
move into residential care because if
they changed it sooner they wouldn't be
paid for any Services they were
receiving at home okay so the
eligibility status is suffered from the
application yes okay thank you
okay a lot of information any further
thoughts from Mr Cahoon okay thank you
anyone else in the audience interested
in talking on House Bill 527 at this
point
okay representative walner could I just
ask um you spoke about Senate bill
um 86 so I just pulled it up my phone I
can barely read it but
it doesn't does it really ever talk
about a rate of
increase
um it seems like it appropriates a large
sum of money and then it leaves it to
the commissioner and yes so uh there
will be an amendment coming to that bill
representative Walnut that will lay out
what the rates would be and I just did
quickly look it up it would be eighty
dollars a day for mid-level care for
these facilities is what we would be
recommending right is the amendment
available now not yet we are
finalizing the uh some of the figures
because not as you might imagine this is
a very large group of stakeholders and
not everyone has completed their
calculations yet
um so we are waiting for those to be
finished before we share them with
Senator Rosenwald
okay oh representative hold please as a
follow-up to representative walner when
said version is available even if it's
not formal can you provide to the
community yes we'd be happy to share it
with the committee when it's finalized
okay thank you very much thank you
um okay a lot to consider here obviously
more information has been relayed to us
in this work session which was very
helpful and productive thank you all uh
representative Edwards has asked Mr
Ripple to schedule an exec session for
the four bills we heard yesterday so
282 614 I'm going to ask that he also
include this bill in that exec session
for a five Bill total for us to consider
what's been relayed to us today and look
further into the Senate bill
sure so I think Monday afternoon might
be a good day to schedule those and I
think as you mentioned earlier this is a
first committee bill so the deadline is
tighter on this one than the other four
because it has to be voted out of
right some have a deadline of March 16th
and this is one good to know okay
representative walner I I just want do
we know what we're doing on Monday
morning
yes I have everything starting next
Monday scheduled as generic budget work
sessions there are no more scheduled
presentations from the department but I
assume you'll begin making decisions
in fact
um I believe it was Janet who sent us a
calendar uh format and on that it says
March 13th for 10 o'clock budget work
session right that's the one
representative yeah
okay anything further on House Bill 527
or for the good of the order at this
point okay I'm going to close the work
session on 527 and that'll be it for
right
foreign